In 2017, the administrative agencies of the
federal government—which many call the administrative
state-- issued over 3000 rules and regulations.
That sounds like a lot, but they have done
that every year since 1993—a total of over
100,000 rules.
Complying with all these rules is estimated
to cost $2 trillion each year—more than
the total taxes paid annually by US businesses
and individuals.
Congress—and now President Trump--have tried
to stanch this flow, but with little success.
These efforts have failed because the courts
have not done what the Framers of the Constitution
expected
They were supposed to narrowly interpret the
laws that give agencies their rulemaking authority
But for many years the courts have allowed
the agencies to interpret the scope of their
own powers.
The Supreme Court, with a conservative majority,
will have an opportunity to change this system
and rein in the administrative state.
The question is whether, after years of neglect,
it will take this important step.
To learn more about my take on the administrative state,
check out the link to my book "Judicial Fortitude" in the description below.
And be sure to like and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI.